hi this is Prussia talker what is the
integral of sine X cosine X let's try
and solve this perplexing integral one
method of attack is to do au
substitution where u equals sine X D u
equals cosine X and we end up with the
integral of u D you this becomes 1/2 u
squared plus an arbitrary constant
substituting back in for u we get the
answer sine squared x over 2 plus an
arbitrary constant but that's not the
only way we could solve this problem we
could have also done a u substitution
where u equals cosine X in that case D u
would equal negative sine X and we end
up with the integral of negative u D u
simplifying this answer we end up with
the result of negative cosine squared
divided by 2 plus an arbitrary constant
this answer is different but we can even
solve the integral in a third way there
is a double angle identity that sine 2x
equals 2 sine X cosine X this means our
integral is equivalent to 1/2 sine 2x
simplifying we get a result of negative
1/4 cosine 2x plus an arbitrary constant
so now we have a very interesting result
we have three different ways that we've
written the answer of the integral sine
X cosine X and they don't look anything
like each other so how is this possible
how do we have three different answers
when we solve this problem in seemingly
valid ways there is a reason for this we
can look at the graph of our three
results and we can notice that the three
graphs the functions of these graph only
differ by a constant amount vertically
since
derivatives are defined only up to a
constant this demonstrates that these
graphs are all corresponding to the same
antiderivative because they only differ
by a constant and each antiderivative
you add an arbitrary constant this shows
that each of our solution all of these
three solutions are equivalent to each
other as anti derivatives but we can
also prove this directly so let's show
that these two solutions are equivalent
that they only differ by a constant
we'll use the trigonometric identity
that sine squared X plus cosine squared
X equals 1 we'll solve for sine squared
X and then we'll substitute into the
first solution we end up with the result
of 1 minus cosine squared X over 2 plus
an arbitrary constant and this
simplifies to negative cosine squared X
over 2 plus 1/2 plus an arbitrary
constant here's what we can simplify 1/2
plus an arbitrary constant is still an
arbitrary constant so we can lump these
terms together to an arbitrary constant
and thus we found out that these two
solutions differ only by 1/2 they differ
by the constant of 1/2 and therefore
they are the same equivalent anti
derivatives let's do the same thing
let's show this third solution is
equivalent to the second solution
we'll use the cosine double angle
identity that cosine 2x equals 2 cosine
squared X minus 1 well substitute that
into our third solution and then we'll
simplify to get again negative cosine
squared X over 2 plus 1/4 plus an
arbitrary constant so this shows the
third second and third solutions differ
only by the constant of 1/4 therefore
they're equivalent to each other because
we can group the arbitrary constants
together thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on so
to media at pressure saw Walker and if
you liked the video please check out my
books there's links in the video
description